thanks for having it here it's been a
really fun workshop so far and what I'll
talk about is Justin shanks a summer
research internship at Facebook where he
examined the problem of how predictable
cascades are and this is joint work with
Alex Thao and you unless commits and jon
kleinberg so this summer this photo is
uploaded to facebook it's a cabela's
receipt cabela's is a sporting goods
store and the caption along with it said
something like the obama administration
doesn't want you to know that you're
paying extra taxes for obamacare but
Cabela's is not afraid to show this and
they've shown separately this medical
excise tax that you're paying for while
you're you know purchasing this talk for
your rifle or your you know pistol
holster or something like that it turns
out Cabela's inadvertently had charged
this tax but it wasn't it was only
supposed to be applied to very expensive
medical devices right so what you'd like
to know is what happens next if I tell
you okay here here's a how many friends
the user who uploaded this has or your
properties of the image it has some text
on it the first few people who reshard
it were they directly friends of the
person who uploaded or did sort of skip
out of that individual's neighborhood
how rapidly did the reshares occur could
you then predict something like this
this is a fraction of the Cascade that
resulted with the leaf nodes removed and
the later v shares are in blue so you
can kind of see a string here it's
branching all over the place goes up
here eventually you know it is something
like that predictable so first how do we
track these cascades now in my facebook
feed unfortunately I didn't have the
cabela's receipt but I get things you
know more science oriented usually so
here's one which is a cake that's made
to look like our planet and if I if I
see this in my feet and then I click
Share I will be placed in this
in the Cascade so here's my friend and
here's my reshare of his reshare or what
i can do is i can click on this because
I want to get a better view of like how
how realistic is that cake but then if i
click Share here what happens officially
is that I've shared directly from the
source and for the purposes of tracking
how information is spreading we don't
want that so we go back through this
click and actually attribute my V share
here just so we sort of keeping track
and so the kind of naive formulation of
the problem or version one is you
observe the first little bit here and
you'd like to predict whether this is
going to happen now there's some very
fun research by Sherrod goal and his
collaborators showing that that pretty
much never happens it's a ninety-five
percent of the time this happens and
they study this across a variety of
different social media maybe three
percent of the time this happens this is
less than one percent forget this right
so your best prediction is actually to
just say it won't spread and you'll be
right the vast majority of the time okay
but you know maybe you just select the
larger Cascades so that you're trying to
predict whether this will happen or
whether this will happen so this is
actually the same cascade just early and
and a little bit later but the critique
there is that the scenario is artificial
and that these large Cascades are really
rare so you know who cares about
predicting really rare events but
there's a lot of research that tries to
predict which hashtags will become
popular which user content will become
popular but focusing on things that were
already hits and then the argument goes
well by the time you've noticed that
they might qualify their faith is
already sealed so prediction in that
case is not as interesting but I'd like
to argue that it might still be useful
to look at this so so first of all it's
true for facebook as well something that
wasn't in the goal data sets when you
look at the probability that a first of
all that anything that something is
reassured at all only 5% of photos
uploaded to Facebook are we sure
and then of those that are we shared
half of a percent re-shared say 500 or
more times which is kind of a decent
number so you know maybe we don't want
to be predicting those but if you look
at the total quantity of reshares that
are accounted for by those things that
were reassured 500 or more times that's
half of it right so we do actually care
about those items because half of what
we see are those items this is the the
most liked I think photo to date this
was posted when obama was reelected it
was reshare in six hundred thousand
times maybe we'd like to because so many
facebook users like millions and
millions were exposed maybe we'd like to
know that that will happen it's not all
Obama's so it's not just Obamacare or
about getting reelected here's a very
enterprising young man from Norway who
used the million like meme he wasn't the
first one to try this ploy like puppies
and kittens had been gotten in this way
but he wanted something else he ended up
being a real gentleman about it because
he did get a million likes and he said
nothing happened we're just friends and
so on but you might think that this kind
of diffusion might look a little bit
different from something posted by the
official Obama page so could you have
predicted that and even if you think oh
we know that it was reshard a lot
because the Obama page posted in the
Obama page has millions of followers
well this second photo was uploaded a
short time after and it only had 80,000
reshares as opposed to 600,000 so are
there factors that you could use to try
to differentiate the two so maybe it's
not just about the original upload so
this is how we ended up formulating the
problem and it allows both for studying
the very large Cascades if that's what
you care about or you can try and
predict them from the very start and
we're just going to get a family of
problems where will vary that number so
rather than saying we're going to
observe only to a certain point and then
predict the Cascade sizes we're actually
going to vary that point so
Skade that has for research so far what
we're going to ask is is it going to
double in size or not and the neat thing
about actually when your cascade sizes
sizes are roughly parallel distributed
with exponent 2 is that the median is
actually twice the current size so if
you just integrate from the size where
you are now and you try to figure out
what this function is where you'll have
a half of the Cascades going to that
size it ends up just being twice that
threshold to which you already observed
the Cascade just a check yeah so we can
now dis track Cascades for different
values of K and the nice result is that
as you increase K you have better and
better prediction accuracy so because
we're our data is kind of split into the
half that reached the the median and the
half that didn't right just random
guessing is is something like fifty
fifty percent right so we're doing much
better than that and I'll get into the
details of our prediction in just a
moment you might also ask whether it
matters once you condition on the final
size of the Cascade so if you're
considering all Cascades for which you
know that eventually they reached a
hundred or more reshares then observing
the cascade through the first 25 then 50
and 75 and hundred reshares increases
your prediction accuracy you do a little
bit worse if you limit yourself to those
that eventually reach 100 to 200 because
you've taken away some of the variance
you don't have the very large cascades
in there and if you know that the
Cascade will eventually reach somewhere
between a thousand and two thousand
reshares then looking at the first few
or even the first hundred doesn't
actually help you that much it's it
really it means that the larger cascades
are less less predictable you may also
then look at the early development of
the Cascade and see whether it has
anything to do with what happened
later on so this is a chain so first
person reshares than someone else and
someone else in someone else vs this is
the other extreme where the reshares are
all directly from the source and what
you can see is that so first of all this
is separated out by pages and users and
four pages things happen more rapidly
because pages tend to have more more
followers than individual users who for
the most part and I think especially for
this analysis we exclude users with lots
and lots of followers so non non public
figures basically 44 pages this happens
a lot more rapidly it would indicate
that it's a page with many followers and
these kind of more complex things take a
little bit longer another thing to look
at is the connections of the first we
share so if it happens that a user
reshares and then someone else reshares
but the subsequent research happen from
that first reshare is as opposed to the
share then the connectivity of that
first reshare tends to be greater we can
actually also make the prediction
problem about the shape of the Cascade
so you might look at the average
distance in the diffusion tree between
any two nodes and you can have things
that are very shallow or just doesn't
show up very well but things that are
very deep and we did the prediction for
that as well and you can do it about
equally equally well this is just to
show that the thing actually we saw with
the Obama photo as opposed to the
million likes me as the size of the
Cascade increases if it's a page you can
get a very large cascade but it can be
very shallow because the the page has
many direct followers as opposed to if a
user uploads it's likely that the
Cascade is actually getting quite deep
as it accumulates more and more B shares
they're also potentially interesting
temporal dynamics
so when the Obama victory photo was
uploaded that's when it got the most
three shares and it was pretty much
downhill from there except I think this
was a michelle obama and then Alicia
Keys kind of drove some of the reshares
on the other hand this is what you might
think of more is kind of an organic
viral development for the million like
mean and it started out small and and
grew and grew and grew in popularity and
sort of peaked here anyone guess what
this point was yeah I got the million
like some people didn't have to be sure
anymore again we can look at how this
difference between pages and users is
shows up in general so the Cascade sizes
drop off more directly for users for
pages it's a little bit the the large
pages sustain larger cascade sizes but
the user cascade because Cade's tend to
be deeper okay so the results in brief
and I'll describe the features in more
detail in just a bit r if we use all the
features we can think of and we really
thought of a lot we get about point a
prediction accuracy but you can get
almost all of this from temporal
features alone I'll get into these in a
little bit if you look at the V sharers
so properties of the first few users who
share you do almost as well if you take
all the features but you subtract the
temporal features you can you can get
most of the way there if you look at
structural features these are the ones
that maybe we find most appealing so if
you look at who's we sharing and then
the friendship ties between them that
doesn't actually tend to do as well you
can look at properties of just the route
that does even more poorly or you can
look at properties of the content is
this an outdoor picture or not okay so
I'll show a series of plots that
basically look at the correlation of
each feature with the Cascade or
actually yeah with whether the
cade reaches a certain size as a
function of observing more and more of
the Cascade and so these are views of
the original photo this is whether the
original uploader was a page and this is
how many connections that original
uploader has and so as you can see the
more the Cascade goes on the less and
less relevant it is whether the origin
was well connected you can look at the
various features of the reshares so
anything from their age to the gender to
how many friends they have or how many
fans are subscribers how many views
there were of their reshares as opposed
to the original how many pages were
among the first k reshares etc and for
the most part what you observe is that
the longer you've observed the Cascade
the more correlated this is so you're
more certain about what the average age
is and what the average gender is and in
general for four ree sharing a lot of
that is driven by somewhat older users
and especially for some kinds of
reshares by female users so those kinds
of features tend to help you the longer
you observe then there's properties of
the content and for the most part it
doesn't really seem to matter is that
indoor/outdoor doesn't have a person or
not what does tend to matter is whether
it has a caption whether it has overlaid
text and whether it's synthetic so
overlay text and synthetic tend to be
properties of memes and memes kind of by
definition are pretty viral and intent
to spread and again this these content
features matter less and less the longer
you've observed the Cascade these are
the structural features which we'd like
to be very predictive so but they
actually function in the way that you
would expect so the subgraph feature is
how interconnected the first K reshare
reshares are so if they're actually all
friends it's negative Italy correlated
because if it's only really of interest
to close group of friends it's not going
to spread as far but to depth is
actually positively correlated so if its
actual
to escape out of that local neighborhood
it tends to spread more and then the
border nodes and border edges are how
many in some how many connections and
ties do the first kV shares have with
the rest of the network so the larger
that is the more it's going to spread
and finally these are the kind of like
the winning features that tend to
dominate the others are how many views
you're getting per unit time of either
the origin so this includes the origin
or just of the V shares how much time is
do you have to wait until the next we
share is the time actually increasing so
there's kind of like an acceleration
measure which is a negatively correlated
meaning if it takes more and more time
the Cascade sort of dying down so it's
not going to grow as as large so all of
these features tend to do well and they
actually continue to be highly relevant
as you're observing the cascade okay so
fantastic right we can do all these
predictions we've thought of every
possible feature so we can predict how
things are going to run their course the
the thing is that maybe one
unpredictable element is when these are
going to occur when they're going to pop
up in the network and so we're usually
pretty surprised to see things like this
so this is one of the most returned
images in July and it says something
like it's just text good luck everyone
this December has five Mondays five
saturdays and five sundays this happens
once every 823 years this is called
moneybags so you know pass this on
you'll get money it's based on some you
know chinese feng shui and you must you
must share this right this is pretty
silly and actually we'd seen this a
couple of years ago when we were looking
at copy and paste mean sorry because
it's just just text except back then it
was october and it was five fridays
saturdays sundays the 823 always stays
it's always that exact number of years
even though it's it's
not true because obviously this happens
pretty often and it's not clear who got
money or anything else but people like
to pass this around and if you look at
least four in the text variants you see
different bursts and it's actually of
different variants so here's october
friday saturday sunday was true in 2010
and then the july is true in 2011 but
then there's a variant once you shift
october to saturday sunday monday that's
actually true in in october of 2011 as
well right so so how does stuff like
this happen like you know it's like it's
gone and then it reimburses well if you
plot the same thing on the log scale
what you see is that even though the the
rise of these things looks pretty
exponential that the key is more power
law right so these things actually
persist in really low numbers somehow
waiting for the conditions to be right
and then they bounce back so if you look
at the beginning of 2011 actually it was
the incorrect October variant that was
kind of cropping up again but it seemed
to then fuel the correction the July
variant which was true right and and and
even the the correct October variant
happened at that time as well another
question is you know can you ever have
especially with things like rumors and
so on can you have an antidote so
Facebook is going to start charging very
old rumor first as far as we know
appeared in Danish in 2009 alive and
well two years later in English even
with like a price grid right like how
much Facebook good start judging and
then what happened was that there was a
parody of it saying that you'd have to
you know do all sorts of crazy things
and then Mark Zuckerberg would
personally you know come come down your
chimney and guarantee that Facebook
would be forever free this actually had
a hundred thousand copies of people like
actually copying and pasting the text
into their status update which then led
to this
you know not not clear the original or
the parodies was more annoying what's
the dynamic of this well here's the
rumor that Facebook is going to start
charging here's the parody but it
doesn't really do much here the price
grid variant arrives and then the parody
actually shoots up and two additional
parodies become popular as well there
are things that don't even register here
that they're kind of more matter-of-fact
look guys you can check the facebook
home page it says it's always going to
be free don't worry about it but but
those don't even register relative to
the kind of parodies which is what what
catches on so you know yes we can
predict some cascades I would say like
good luck you know predicting things
like this so to conclude we think we
found a principled way to just formulate
the problem of predicting cascades in
the first place which is let's observe
it until kV shares and see if it's going
to double in size or not and what we see
then is that individual features which
you might like and you might think oh
it's it's all the content or it's all
the original etc actually very as you
vary k the amount of time that you'll
allow yourself to to track the Cascade
and then finally all of this kind of
addresses like if you haven't upload and
now you're it's like it's fresh and now
you've seen the initial steps and you're
trying to predict it but just figuring
out where in the network things are
going to pop up might be the difficult
part so thanks
the fact that different things are
predicting things at different times you
have any idea whether that's because
different types of cascades last for
different periods or whether it's
actually that has something to do with
the learning that you're undergoing so
there's this it could be that there's a
sorting that certain kinds of rulers are
always are short and things that are
funnier go longer another you can
imagine stories for why there's going to
be different ages and if you look back
at the age and then go backwards can you
tell whether that's the reason that
you're getting this fact that different
things are yeah I think that would be
really valid just too I mean so we did
look at separate predictions for things
that are uploaded by pages versus users
and different features are dominant for
four different kinds of cascades with
the users typically being user-initiated
ones typically being the ones that
build-up and then fall off gradually
pages usually start high and then and
then decay so in that very coarse sense
yes different features pop up
differently but we didn't look at their
dependence on K separately for four
pages and users but certainly yes I
think different features like the
acceleration might matter more for the
user-generated cascades that are slowly
growing as opposed to pages where just
the number of reshares to a certain time
point might be most of what you need to
know so if you were trying to attract
cascades of certain types it might be
the same information
valuable over time interests that you'd
have to sort by types rather than
looking at all the Cascades right right
and it's not clear that you know how to
separate that ahead of time right yep in
your structural features did you look at
anything that corresponds to people
think that diffusion models like
neutrality hosted it already and whether
that so we only looked at degree I think
and yes it was was predictive so we
looked at you know in aggregate what
what is the connectivity of these users
or but that was in that category
structural that was less productive than
the temporal actually know so that was
in the reshare category which did pretty
well so there we just aggregated how you
know degree centrality of the of the
reshares and then also try to account
for whether their networks are
overlapped or not just to see okay if
you do anything real analysis and find
any correlation with legs maybe seasons
the universal connection these things
all right i think the the the most we
did was a time of week and and day just
because they had so many different
Cascades and there's little doubt that
timing does matter one thing that that
we did was we looked at the same image
being uploaded multiple times the
thinking was that if you're early your
cascade might spread and then either the
network's exhausted or it's no longer
relevant and so the later kind of seeds
won't be as successful but there was
only a very weak correlation it wasn't
necessarily the first or even the second
upload that led to the large cascade it
could happen later just adding to the
unpredictability I was the placement
people have more time to share the
things like any and all these people are
more browsing and its share more and
correlates to the team of statement may
be much more relevant to describe
I mean when you examine individual
instances it really makes sense so a
Warren Buffett rumor about how to fix
Congress was even though is uploaded
originally in January really flared up
during the government shutdown right it
makes sense but if you're doing the
prediction in general you can't really
dealt that much into it so I really like
the idea of trying to formulate this
predictability is not is it predictable
or not but as you accumulate more
information how does that change how
much you can predict and it seems like
you formulated this a lot in terms of
the number of free shares that you've
seen but then another thing that you
talked about a lot with the importance
of time and speed so I'm wondering why
did you pick the big number of features
of dirt instead of time that's been
passed right there's their mirror
problems right so if you if you do the
other problem and some folks have done
this but you know not in a systematic
way but they would just say okay we're
going to look at the first day and then
predict from there on out and it's it
really is then the number of reshares up
to that point is the most predictive
right because I feel it's it's both of
them kind of get at the rate and yeah we
could have formulated it the other way
around but this just made it easier our
it's not really the reason but one nice
feature of this in addition is that for
the structural features then you're
always dealing with the first k and you
kind of can enumerate the sub graphs and
so on versus if you're if you're going
up to a given time right the the
structure sort of all over the place
because you have a variable number of
nodes but yeah certainly you can
formulate the problem the other way too
why don't we stop here
Oh